[Music]
something beside me has always been and
I was awake
[Music]
I need help
I've seen this roster only once before
but to scare me enough that
it does now
[Music]
but the pastime
we are the spark little light the fire
time for the Jedi
to end
[Music]
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
hey everybody we're almost a month away
from Star Wars they just dropped a new
trailer let's break it down they changed
some of the cuts in this to for clarity
I think and it was a big interview over
the weekend with Adam driver supposedly
saying a whole bunch of stuff about
Rey's character I'll explain what he was
probably talking about I don't think
it's exactly what a lot of news outlets
are reporting it to be I don't think he
actually gave away any spoilers the
ticket giveaway is still going on - I'll
explain that at the end of the video but
just be sure to subscribe to get
everything
so probably the biggest change in this
trailer is the addition of a couple
characters like c-3po obviously we knew
he was going to be in the movie he was
also in the behind-the-scenes video that
I posted a couple days ago
and there's a couple different ships
that we see the characters on in that
they correspond to some of the shots in
this trailer - but in addition to that
they also released a Japanese poster
because this trailer is basically like
the Japanese trailer it's a really cool
riff on the last poster that they
released so they're obviously sticking
with that road motif they've just
shifted the characters positions and now
Luke is holding his father's lightsaber
an array is up at the top here so for
everybody that was making that Darth
Vader helmet comparison like the evil
character always goes up in Darth
Vader's spot up here because of all the
visual metaphors - the classic films
original trilogy Darth Vader was
typically the shadow that was above all
the other characters like he was always
watching them coming for them so when
that last poster was released everyone's
like oh my god Luke is in the Darth
Vader spot even Mark Hamill got in on
the fun just trolling the fans a little
bit now they have rey up here and even
though i don't think that they're
telling you that she's going to become
evil I think the more darker aspects of
her personality will come out during the
film because of all the heavy themes
that the film is trading in like the
whole idea that the darkside is
overshadowing everything that they're
doing it's the darkest film in the
trilogy so you have this character with
infinite potential wouldn't it make
sense that given the right set of
circumstances in the push in the wrong
direction she would go dark but
ultimately I don't think that's what the
trailer is trying to say I think it's
trying to say that things are going in a
different direction they just want to
tease you with the idea that people
might go super dark
in kylo Ren extending his hand out there
I think it's much clearer that this shot
is not connected to this shot of her
saying I'm looking for someone to show
me my way I think this is what she's
still talking to Luke Skywalker on Ock -
and she's trying to understand where
he's coming from and explained why she
needs so much help but there are also
some better shots of her taking the dive
off the cliff and coming back out it
sounds like that might be a version of
her Luke Skywalker Dagobah cave scene
where she confronts the darkness within
her this isn't going to go the way you
think it's going to go a lot of people
also saw that shot and that line of
dialogue from Luke Skywalker sort of
looking like he's gotten a beatdown and
he's staring up at somebody who's coming
after him and a lot of people saw that
and thought that it might be connected
to a flashback scene when the Knights of
Ren come to destroy the Jedi Temple
so because Luke Skywalker's holding his
father's lightsaber in this poster not
his classic green lightsaber he
constructed before Return of the Jedi
there are a lot of theories that kylo
Ren and the Knights of Ren just took
that Sabre when they burnt down the
temple their combined forces and
whatever else they brought with them
that we haven't seen whatever larger
force and then that's when they took
Luke Skywalker's lightsaber because I
think there were a lot of questions in
the last trailer after Luke has that
line of dialogue where he says I saw
this raw power once before it didn't
scare me then but it scares me now like
he's afraid of Rey and what she might
become in present day but that past
power was talking about kylo Ren so
that's why you see this alternate cut in
the trailer when he says that it goes
straight to the shot of kylo Ren in his
helmet picking up the saber off the
ground in Snoke ship so there's still a
lot of misleading shots but they just
want to clarify a couple story beats
like kylo Ren was supposed to be the
chosen one in Luke's mind in the past
making that line this isn't going to go
the way you think is going to go even
more meaningful so we talked a little
bit about Rey as the new supposed chosen
one at least in the mind of Snoke in now
Luke Skywalker and present-day both of
them having a lot of ideas about what
they want to do with that potential for
power but Adam driver did a big GQ
interview recently where he talked about
a bunch of story beads and character
beads one of them implied some backstory
for Ray but a lot of people are taking
his comments out of context so this is
what he actually said he says you have
also the hidden identity of this
princess who's hiding who she really is
so she can survive in kylo Ren and her
hiding behind these artifice ah's and
then even within the article they take
that to mean her royal origins as in
people are now thinking that Rey is
secretly a princess who's been in hiding
and that's part of the reason why they
hid her on jakku in addition to being
the next potential chosen one of the
force what I think was actually going on
with his comment is that he was speaking
in metaphors and he was using the term
princess as an analogue of chosen one of
the force like she's a princess of the
force not literally a princess in the
way that Princess Leia was actually a
princess of Alderaan but you guys can
let me know in the comments what do you
think that Adam driver was talking about
when he said that she's a princess who's
trying to hide her identity behind these
layers and they'll start peeling the
layers back in the next two films but
what will happen is because they're
dropping more footage in the world
series is this week as I'm posting the
video there might actually be another
really big trailer with completely
different footage sometime in the next
week or two so if that happens I'll
totally do a video for it the ticket
giveaway is still going on all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the last giveaway
winner GG ninja please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details click here
for more brand new Star Wars and click
here to listen to Jeffrey Dean Morgan
talked all about being flashpoint Batman
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you